look it's not our fault he has he's been
on a roll
is it our boys
[Music]
so let's get after it and have us
we'll go [ __ ] bread
um
we have we've been we were blessed today
because normally I was like I will push
up we do Como a bit but he did another
walk and talk he did another walk and
talk I don't know if there's a dead bird
in this one but you know the surprise he
can do both things yeah it's really
amazing
two dead birds welcome to another walk
and talk it's cold that's good why
because I decided this three points what
the [ __ ] what
so he thinks he's God
seven seconds and he's already [ __ ]
mentally [ __ ] I love him
that's good why because I decided this
three points kiss
preferred indifference what kiss
keep it simple stupid is this a trivia
game what are we doing I don't know what
is Gene Simmons
who is Gene Simmons
why is Gene Simmons
where is Gene Simmons
guys he's trying to tell you a riddle
he's going you know I'm tall but I'm
round kiss
and the first this is this okay tell
Batman I should kiss
1947 the Hindenburg
bread he'll know what it means one kiss
sir please drop that bird he still has
it in his pocket it's Friday goes to get
a cigar and he's like I forgot about the
bird a little skeleton now Stray Cats
following him I wonder why my jacket was
stinking
comes from no specific derivation but it
is a point that philosophy is not
complicated it doesn't have to be
complicated it just gives you a feeder
road to your why and now remember we've
been bringing this up he's been getting
a lot into reading well listening to
books and he he's really getting into
philosophy now life and he probably
doesn't like read the original
philosopher's books he gets like the
dumbed down versions The Secret yeah is
so important
kiss keep it simple every book he reads
has Oprah's Book Club sticker on it
or is this partner that I work for dumb
it's simple it's stupid it's keep its
kiss kiss is not k-i-s not keep it
simple kiss it stands for keep it simple
stupid yeah
well with him the stupid's implied he
doesn't want to say the word because he
knows he's stupid
or is this partner that I worked for at
a law firm keep it simple stupid oh
there you go he thinks it was a partner
at a law firm that came up with the
stupid simple stupid has always been the
phrase since I was a kid yeah yeah what
are you talking about
keep it simple
what is philosophy
I don't know man but I would rather have
somebody else explain it to me yeah I
mean I don't quite know the origins of
philosophy either but I'd rather speak
to anyone but you about it yeah
well it's the study of knowledge but I
mean I'm sure you know all the facts
about the Godfather movies I'm sure if I
sat down and talked to you about that
would be a great talk but not this
philosophy you [ __ ] idiot is not the
study of knowledge literally any reading
is the studying of knowledge it's
studying studying is studying of
knowledge
what else are you reading
easiest application to life
this is
his separates package from CNN
the last email Brian Stelzer sent him
kind he's reading I drank what a
Socratic pop-up book okay no there's not
his last email from stelter was
complaining that he's not putting his
couple of bucks in the uh break room
coffee fund
I see you Chris you get coffee but you
never put you never you gotta give you
got to give otherwise the coffee dries
up it was dark
so I was reading Nietzsche for dummies
and let me tell you what I learned
apparently some dude killed God and
there was blood everywhere
and so I was reading Machiavelli of
stoneads
he was a [ __ ] smart guy that guy
that's how I had Tupac renamed himself
after him
but he didn't spell it right on account
of him being a black a movie
so I was reading those toys War and
Peace just kidding I was reading the
ingredients on a half-eating marinara
jar of the boy no he was reading War and
Peace but he was reading the comic book
version from the movie Major League
remember when they got on the plane yeah
and he goes oh War and Peace what is
that like a detective novel and he's
like uh yes and he's like you want to
trade remember he's reading Moby Dick
Comics they all had comic versions
be kind jobs Lou Ferrigno philosophy
means quote the love of studying
are you kind
probably say yes for instance like you
know sometimes uh I'm telling the whole
country you gotta lock down and follow
my Elite rules right and then I catch
cover but I still go out for a nice walk
try to go kill some birds My Neighbor
comes up he starts talking [ __ ] me you
know what I do I'm very nice I tell him
get the [ __ ] out of here if I break your
legs I could have just broke his legs
but you also probably they say Chris you
got covered stay home I just wants to
eat my wife's [ __ ] cooking
not practice it on the regular
sure I do you don't know me
uh pretty sure I got you figured out but
you're an angry hawk-headed Italian man
who is who's infinitely less smart than
he believes himself to be sure I've met
you a million times in my life I've met
a million of you you just happen to be
blessed with the last name Cuomo that's
it without that you're every jack off
from Nassau County I met my entire life
but you know hey oh it's like close to
the city but it's not as expensive up
that stupid tweet
that snide comment
if you're green with your friend making
videos every day and may having a song
they're about bread and me liking it I'm
not going to get specific but some
people's in my algorithm now and I don't
[ __ ] like it look I don't care for it
I don't care for it I don't know who
these people are the role of ethnically
questionable Origins and I want them off
my timeline I want them out of my
neighborhood
how about unflattering gossip about
something you see this no way they get
their bread this is a Jew Italian
neighborhood that's it I want people to
live here all right then we got the
[ __ ] uh we got uh what's his face it
was the [ __ ] uh Epstein attorney uh
uh uh um oh [ __ ] the Jew
yeah never mind
the Jewish attorney we got dershowitz's
nephew down the street and over here on
the cul-de-sac we got Anthony cumia okay
it's a tines of Jews only right yeah
we made the agreement it was called the
same nose agreement
foreign
we call it the schnoz claws
we call it that's why we got nearby we
call it the noble nose Country Club
those Jews just later about it
contentiousness
Pride
competitiveness
like I said that twice it's all
indication of where my head is
up your ass
we're not kind as a matter of practice
why because we're weak
flawed well not you you're on steroids
you
the
thing
he's he really is the epitome of like
just not being self-aware like again
he's a hot-headed douchebag selfish
[ __ ]
and he's doing this he he he knows he's
not any of these things he just wants
you to think he is he's trying to
Rebrand and it's not sorry buddy I'm not
buying it I am not buying it you know
what you are right now your heel AJ
Styles it [ __ ] sucks I don't want it
you're a baby face knock it off
you know
yeah stop trying to be stop trying to
pull stop trying to force this on me we
know what you are be what you are do you
showing a [ __ ] wife beater cook some
sauce while you tell talking philosophy
he already reminds me of
it's it's like if Mark Harley tasted
success
oh yeah that's a good way
selfish
be kind
keep it simple sir you are a human
dollar slice wrapped in a three thousand
dollar suit that's all you are
it's really sad in all applications be
kind
you have questions about what's really
sad is that Cuomo keeps killing all the
[ __ ] the local birds like a
neighborhood can't Straight Cat [ __ ] it
yeah that's why they they don't even fly
south of the winter anymore they just do
it's a flea [ __ ] Chris
honey we gotta go to Florida it starts
getting cold out he starts snapping bird
necks like a lunatic he gets really
aggressive that's why he holds the
camera because if he was holding it
straight back you'd see the neighbors
there chasing around trying to put a
[ __ ] Bell on his neck
honey Como's at it again he's chasing
the neighbor he's chasing the birds
practice of kindness
wasn't that weak am I aren't I going to
give in all the time absolutely not
hell I'm not even going to give in some
at a time I'll never admit I'm wrong
I've been very clear about that
your kid says you drink alcohol why
can't I drink alcohol and you're like
you can't shut the [ __ ] up I'll give you
one we did every night just like my Nana
did with me
because you're not at the age where it's
legal
and because yeah what age is it legal
for all the steroids they're taking what
age is that also how much drinking you
doing around your kids
an Italian amount
because
I believe the med I believe the unit of
measurement is one gavone
so he drinks about six gavones of wine a
day I just don't I mean you know how
much drinking those are on your kids
though that they're bringing it up a lot
right yeah it has to be I want you to
learn how to make good choices Dad I see
you drinking at 10 A.M why can't I yeah
dad you're drinking while you're doing
your podcast yesterday it was one in the
afternoon
and you're going through like five
cigars a day oh get off my ass I had
Nick ricadon what do you want from me
noon [ __ ] 12 or 9 10 in the afternoon
what do you want from me we're gonna be
drinking if he's around
it's for yourself
and I want you to see that you don't
have to be dependent
on what everybody else is doing to know
who you are
they are very up they're unhappy they
say you were unkind no no honestly dude
every uh
every person that does this kind of
content constantly he's a profoundly
unhappy person everybody I've ever seen
that does this like these [ __ ]
inspirational walk and talk type things
and all you always talk about is being
kind and being nice being happy you're
none of these things so to me it's you
just talking to yourself like you should
just be having this conversation with
yourself you're not fooling any of us we
all know you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] so
this whole gimmick is you just trying to
convince yourself like gotta be happy
you gotta stay positive you gotta you
know sometimes you gotta give you gotta
be charitable you gotta be basically
like Christ reborn on Earth you know
what I mean and that's like what I like
to do you know and I know what I like to
do is I like to be kind I like to be
nice to everybody and I like to be and
then I like to tell everybody about all
of the nice things I do all the time
that's what nice people do
I like to remind you all the time of
like money I've given you before things
I've done for you hey remember that
thing I got you the jacket
yeah every time age you know that
Anonymous donation that was me
he's that was Larry David in that
episode yeah yeah exactly Ted dance it's
Anonymous and give it up for Chris Cuomo
inactive kindness with him doing it oh
I'm sorry I didn't know I could be
anonymous but not being I know I could
be anonymous and tell everybody
you deliver it see what I'm saying oh my
hand's cold okay I better get another
dead bird in it to warm it up okay so
you can keep it simple
still stupid
[Laughter]
no I wasn't finishing the thing this is
a new sentence
a lot of philosophy works that way
do good be kind love Mercy that's not
I'm sorry pause that's not that none of
those things have anything to do with
philosophy philosophy is like
existentialism uh the the how did Life
Begin meaning of life and like yeah and
like even Ventures into Political uh
theories and then things of that nature
but no it's not is is be kind a
philosophy sure it's like one thing but
he's doing more a Be Kind Rewind
philosophy it's like you gotta turn your
videotapes in but the next guy is going
to watch him now two and a half hour
movies and take wow to get it all the
beginning yeah get your Blockbuster
philosophy out of here you piece of [ __ ]
implications of it derivations of it
the message is the same
keep it simple
stupid
be kind
it works internally also by the way or
self-directed
well how are you kind to yourself
well how do you treat yourself bro how
how are you on CNN and we're dunking on
your numbers wise like I don't get it
like no one's watching these three
thousand views
well because I'm nationally syndicated
hosts Because unless you're watching him
to laugh at him like we are who's really
watching this [ __ ] who's sitting through
this everybody I guess everybody we've
shown the video to is the only people
that are actively looking at it now
I walked to the cemetery
for mostly the ranger family here where
I live very old early 1800s even 1700s
and I said are they own blacks put the
cell floating away I just had I just had
ROTC comments RT's comment what happened
to the bird Chris
it's all we need I need to know
you never told us you never told us what
happened to that bird I'd like to know
what happened to the bird I need
everybody to ask him what happened to
the bird there you go here you go that's
a good that's a good point here you guys
let me put the postal link here and this
isn't this is just asking because we
want to know the well further please ask
Chris there's you guys to link it's his
latest walk and talk
um ask him what's up with the bird we
want to know what happened to the bird
because I really want to release this
next year be like a lot of people leave
me comments about the bird let me tell
you what happened I cooked them up in a
risotto it was delicious a little pesto
sauce delicious
when you come for that little oil and
garlic
you know but no but back to philosophy
you know it's like I like I always tell
people you know fear is the pair to the
dark side you know and that's a
philosophy that's normal very famous one
that's Star Wars they say feel he's the
anger right and anger leads to you so
scared into some guy in the Hamptons
because he calls you Fredo and then you
give [ __ ] fire because your brother's
grabbing everybody's titties what was I
talking about oh the bird the bird
so he's dead
and I wouldn't be here really certainly
not the way I was allowed to be if not
for Jewish uh one Jewish man in
particular who wait wait because my
grandfather in who was digging Graves
digging ditches taught him the grocery
business gave him a really favorable
lease molested him on his grocery store
that he let him live behind raised his
family there
so
my father's brother wound up being in
the same business and my father was very
proud of him your father was in the same
business the [ __ ] Mafia racket we
know what your father did bro
uh proud of him for a lot of reasons but
what's the point what's the hobo chili
recipe my Italian Heritage has become
the Olive Garden thanks Chris you half a
movie
it's how you use your situation
what's so bad about Olive Garden JB ski
says Chevy says so we can blame the
juice for Chris Cuomo too
God damn it man you're not making a case
for him [ __ ] Kanye's not like I know it
how you see the situation of others
preferred uh by the way if you want to
refresh I think we got some more oh
really okay let's check it out I think
more people are asking about maybe we'll
go we'll go let's go to news first what
do you say 103. do we ever find out what
happened to the bird I care about the
bird infinitely more than I care about
Chris where's the bird that was you
merge
uh uh let's see do us dolphin uh you put
the bird out of it did you put the bird
out of his misery uh greasy PanAm hi
Chris do you still have the dead bird in
your pocket what did you do with that
bird Chris I'm dying to know what
happened with this purse
great I love it okay this is perfect
good job guys
we need an update yeah we do need to
find out when you know what's going on
with the bird I follow I saw these two
Knuckleheads made them move made up made
a video about me what is this about
I'm nice to everybody there's all this
bird talk
honestly man this is how the movie The
Cell started and I don't know if we
should be diving into this this is that
was a terrible movie what you do what
did you do with the bird Chris tell us
it's fate where's the bird Chris sir
just wanted to know the welfare of the
bird kind of hungry that was Frozen
Thank you Frozen well Frozen no come on
Frozen it's a little dance question okay
will you eat you Filipino people are
very weird